also mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich bekomme in letzter zeit sehr
sehr sehr sehr viele kommentare von
wegen ich sag mal wieder vorn mitspielen
die sache ist nur dass sich in diesem
spiel leider unglaublich beschissen bin
und zum glück hat ein kumpel von mir
gesagt dass er lust hat mal wieder mit
mir zu spielen von daher seht ihr jetzt
regie und mich wie wir vor neid spielen
und wie das aussieht wenn wir zusammen
fordert spielen da wurde ich habe hier
eine blaue ehrlich so hab ich s hatten
schlechter vor dem spiel als mal kommen
das rennen machen
ich bin runtergeflogen anderer spieler
der super leute sogar deshalb das motto
der hatte cdu gehen wir raus teilte
towerstars okay aber du wirst schon
sehen wenn du verlierst dann nehme ich
gewinne doch ich bin der heftig so
kannst du selber gar nicht wissen luca
war es kommt immer darauf an ob du das
auch mit herren- oder leidenschaftlich
mit mit leidenschaftlichen unbedingt mit
herz oder leidenschaft headline schafft
womit spiel zu beherrschen den herzog
herausgesprungen warum sprichst du schon
raus ich habe unseren ich hab mir das
sagen lasst doch so spielen dass mich
mein rausfallen sich sogar recht
eigentlich nicht mehr so beschissen
heraus ja ich da dann fliegt auch und
man weiß nicht was man fliegt runter
wenn man da unten leute leuchtet wenn
man im voraus springen fliegt man
meistens nach unten ich habe relativ
chillige sachen hätte er eine waffe doch
gar keine und ich bin tot tot
ja natürlich wie gut es mir gut geht ja
somit jetzt blendend wie gehts hier
ich nutze auch öfteren blender wie sagt
doch wie ich muss mich konzentrieren
okay wir gehen dahin wo wir hingehen ja
ja das ist gut
okay okay was okay helfers jaja da wo
ich gern mal hier dann gehen wir hin
darum gebe ich ins blaue wollten bloß
scheiße herausfiel neisser wissensturm
kompletten park
wenn die kiste ja ich dachte du kommst
mir wieder alles meine waffe besonnen
was unter seiner drin sein auf dem dach
habe ihn fast habe ich richtig gut
genommen
ja ich bin komplett down telegabel
herrscher gegeben ja ich hab ich habe
das alles unter kontrolle
achtung kein problem kein problem ich
habe den blick einmal hast du dich
einmal gilt ist ehrlich ja ich glaube
nicht er hat 100 bist du schon raus
gesprungen war das spiel so funktioniert
egal du springst auf einer höhe raus mit
dem ort dann bist du am schnellsten doch
jetzt hat sich diese kreise hier dann
kriegen sie zuerst das kann ich hier
noch ja ich mache auch gerade challenge
hier noch nicht fliegen schweben die
rega 35 ein haus weiter liegen natürlich
[Musik]
jetzt geht's los hier nämlich jetzt
geht's los jetzt heißt ihr jetzt geht so
los ist normal sagen ach du tot 2 habe
ich auch dritten hat das besucht über
uns dass du mal rankommen ich schaff das
nicht mehr sagt magath nicht einmal
ruhig kommen wir her kommen ärzte mir
bitte sagen wir ruhig doch lieber eine
tasche fest haben die programme festung
mann
baby alles gut ich bin tot 88
ja das will ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so
gut du bist aber auch einfach jemand der
einfach unglaublich scheiße dem game ist
kann man ja noch sagen ja rewe was
denkst du schaffen was diesmal warum
nicht aber es komme jetzt einmal ruhig
da muss man ein bisschen motivierter
sein das muss man wirklich mal sagen
kommt nicht darauf an ob man gewinnen
sondern auch die stimme und mittendrin
abbricht wenn man was sagt ja stimmt das
hast du ja genau und dann ist man
nämlich ist ein guter form stimmt und
was wird anders sondern direkt in
schrift rein fliegen wussten hier dürft
ich weiß nicht ich hab ich könnte als
bauen für dich okay das ruft meine ich
jetzt ok alles gut ich hab ich habe ja
okay ich habe eine fünfmal getroffen
seitdem ist ihr revier wo bist du denn
direktimporte juni hervor doch bis dahin
kommen wo ich bin ich
ich kann nur hoffen kann der herr
interesse jetzt beruhigt dich erst noch
wie kann man so schlecht seien gestorben
diese hohen so findet eine perfekte
partner nicht eine pistole ja nächste
nächsten entwicklungen oliven stück hat
es nachvollziehen wo ich bin falls ich
in gefahr sein sollte wie ich laufe
jetzt direkt zu dir
ich kenn ich doch
es ist relativ neu auf youtube ja von
youtube hennig sind irgendwelche größte
youtube bei der lieblingsmotive bist du
bist mein absoluter lieblingspuppe alter
das ist neues dank mehr dk ich hatte
keinen bock mehr an weil ich habe mit
mehr ist ein ehrenvoller hier vorne rum
ist deine ich habe gerade einen headshot
bekommen den sprung nach der recht ultra
viel spaß hier wieder mit dir los los
los los los dann mach ich doch mal
gemeldet noch mal hoch egal ich muss
kurz einen töten
gibt es auch nach unten oder nach oben
zentriert werden
zentriert quer ab oftmals dreieck dann
auf die fresse viertel vor sieben oder
zehn vor sieben nicht 37 als bei uns
nein das würde ich zurück nehmen das
auch über 90 quadratmeter so groß ist
und ich lerne mal direkt da oben bei
einer kiste alles klar lande du halt
nicht in ordnung das ist überhaupt nicht
weiter schlimm geil ich habe so eine
waffe was für eine wende die schießen
kann wird schlüsse oder nicht mit
schürze tatsächlich ja mit münster
grunde gar nicht nötig hatte ging es für
dich ich hatte tränke für dich
[Musik]
wirft aber auch jedes mal so dass sie
sich selber auch immer dritte
ich will dass wir zusammen tanzen junge
hengst selber ab das versuchen wir sind
beides und rot zu uns im keller ich sehe
kein luca sind beide schon tot ist beide
getötet warum spiele ich damit dir noch
mit lagen ist lang und jetzt kommt doch
einfach mit politischen spielen die
spieler aber wir bekommen aber dazu mir
völlig egal
2000 jahre später kann man jetzt mir
reden ja ich bin unterwegs
oh mein gott ich habe mein leben ich
habe dem gerade übels gegeben der sich
die ganze zeit geführt
ok ja ich bin unterwegs ich hab halt wie
gesagt mein leben und das beruhigt
er ist gestorben waren tot
viele schon diesmal eine gute runde ich
habe bisher sechs skills die versuche
das tat weh getan hast du gewusst hat
ich habe generell kopfschmerzen auch
wovon von hubsen im rücken hat das board
aufeinander auch wenn du rufst krise
kopfschmerzen und kopfschmerzen habe
kriege ich rutschen
ach so das letzte gegner auf sw holen
doch von oben an
was ist das es ist es hier gehen wir
doch dieses haus oder eben drauf
erklärte verkaufen ich war vorhin drauf
das hat geklappt wir aber du bist
gestorben dann ja unten weil ich keine
gute waffe aber du bist aber bisher
bestätigt man ein bisschen mehr wie ich
erst mal ein bisschen mehr gleiten genau
ecstasy viel höher sein als alle anderen
oder ja genau das das wichtigste wie
sagt man so schön die letzte wurden wird
vom vogel gebremst genau das sage ich
auch immer mehr wo bist du okay ich sehe
wo du bist okay bin bei dir oder weniger
dessen typ und hat jetzt ein typ unter
www mach dir nichts draus
ich bin jetzt sofort da mbabi muss ja
der typ ich musste mich eben durch die
küche kämpfen
dann helfe ich dir sofort hatte ich bin
sofort ball ja ich weiß das schon total
verzweifelt kurz konzentrieren muss ich
mich ja ok kleiner aufwand nicht sogar
den tod ist aber nicht weiter schlimm
weil du hast ja junge ich habe keinen
bock mehr hat dann tatsächlich das
telefonat verlassen und wir sind jetzt
keine freunde mehr
meine damen und herren wenn euch dieses
fordert video hier vielleicht trotzdem
gefallen haben sollte obwohl wir sehr
sehr schlecht in diesem spiel anlass
gerne einen daumen hoch da soll ich
vielleicht wieder öfter hochladen
schreibt zu geld und die kommentare und
jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]